well welcome everyone it's really great
to see
so many of you in this zoom room and i
want to thank you on behalf of the
department of african american studies
for making the time
to think and to
critique and to plan
with us in what has been an
extraordinary set
of seminars this past summer this past
semester
that we've devoted to to really
thinking about and and learning about
new modes of activism
to address the crises that are shaping
our time
we've thought about elections and voting
rights which are still
haunting and aching at us as we speak
um we've been thinking about health care
and as a
as a justice movement especially for
formerly incarcerated people we've been
thinking about the role of
art and artists and protests and social
justice movements
um and today and in the next
and final session that we'll be um
posting this semester we're going to be
thinking about the histories the
cultural logics
the institutional practices and agents
that manage
the carsonal state and to think about
how we dismantle it
or to use a phrase that i was reminded
of
teaching james baldwin's great novel
about this very crisis if beale street
could talk
how do we take apart the jaws of this
democratic hell
called the prison called the police
state so
that's our discussion today my colleague
crystal speemster will introduce our
panelists shortly
i just want to point to the next
conversation we'll be having
about this topic on december 10th after
thanksgiving break at 11 45
our colleague elizabeth henton wonderful
brilliant historian
of the history of mass incarceration
will be in conversation
with tracy mears our colleague and ally
in the law school
and they'll be talking about the work
that the justice collaboratory
um that's housed in the lat in law
school
uh they'll explain that group's work and
we can open up how we might partner with
them
and the great work that they're doing i
want to give thanks
excuse me i'm here to you know nothing
can happen without collaboration in the
age of zoom especially
and i want to thank um our co-sponsor
for these seminars uh the center for
race
the study of race indigeneity and
transnational migration rhythm
um the director steve pitty and the
assistant director matthew tanika have
been
just absolutely wonderful partners in
organizing
and helping us uh mobilize these
discussions and i want to thank them
i want to thank the staff in
african-american studies vanessa epps
our senior administrative assistant
who's been really wonderful of stepping
up and getting the word out to bring you
all here
and to emmanuel bissell who is uh has
been
our tech guru uh making sure that
everything works so well on the back end
of the zoom
uh room and i also want to thank
especially
uh my colleague crystal feemster who
teaches uh she's a brilliant brilliant
historian
of african american history across the
eras i guess what's so stunning to me
about crystal that there's no period
that she does not
know how to engage in and fully
grasp it and she has been the brilliant
mind who's organized and curated the
panels
for this semester so i want to thank her
for her work and her leadership on this
and i'll turn it over to her to
introduce our panelists
thank you um jackie but i want to
extend my gratitude to all the folks
rita vanessa emmanuel as well
it goes without saying that it takes a
village
and i couldn't do this without
the support of my chair jackie goldsby
and all of my colleagues in
african-american studies
and rhythm who have stepped up to
basically participate in these
conversations um i want to before i
introduce our guest today i'd like to
remind you of the format and the format
is that we will have a conversation
between philip goff and philip mcharris
for about 45 to 50 minutes and then
around 4 o'clock
we'll open up for q a we ask that you
submit your questions to
phil mcharris in the private chat link
um he'll moderate the q a
and and try to consolidate some
questions
so that we can get everybody's questions
in today
part of the reason we're asking you to
do that is because we are filming and
recording so that this can be available
to folks who couldn't be here today um
and
if you come in and out of the screen it
means we've got to get permission
to to record you or engage in some
serious editing
um so but having said that we want to
make sure that everybody who wants to
participate in the conversation can do
so
and on that note um i want to say
it is both an honor and a privilege um
to be able to present
um and introduce um to my colleagues
in african-american studies i'll start
with um philip ateeba golf
i hope i said your middle name right i
can massacre names but
i'm gonna say ativa again and then
you're gonna correct me later okay
as a professor of african american
studies and psychology
at yale university yay welcome
and the co-founder and ceo of the center
for policing
and equity a research and action think
tank on race and policing
he is a leading scholar in the science
of racial bias
and has pioneered scientific experiments
that expose how our minds learn to
associate blackness
and crime explicit and implicitly often
with deadly consequences dr golf has won
two american psychological association
early career awards the association of
psychological science rising star award
and the national organization of black
law enforcement executives
lloyd g silly award among many others
he regularly appears on cable news
provides
congressional testimony and was a
panelist for the president obama task
force on
21st century policing
i'd like to turn to his interlocutor
today
who will be framing and moderating our
discussion
and that is phillip v mcharris
who is a phd candidate in the joint
program of african american studies in
sociology
at yale university phillips main
area of research include race
and ethnicity housing policing and
inequality
his current research focuses on the
experience of residents of a high
rise public housing development in
brooklyn new york
as they navigate concerns surrounding
safety
policing building conditions and cycles
of poverty
in another line of his research philip
examines
the causes and consequences of the
large-scale expansion
of policing in the united states since
1965
and the strategies that communities
employ to challenge
police expansion and and police violence
philip draws on qualitative and
quantitative methods throughout his
research
in addition to his scholarly work
phillip has
written for outlets that include the new
york times washington post
post and slate his commentary has been
featured on hbo
cnn time and pbs phillip is a recipient
of the ford foundation predoctorial
fellowship and the nsf
graduate research fellowship um welcome
and i'm going to turn it over um
to um phil m at this point
we'll have to keep track of this but um
thank you for that jackie and crystal
um yeah hello everyone it's a pleasure
to be here with you all today
and i'm eager to have this discussion
around policing
i want to offer a few points to ground
the conversation today
but first i want to lift up all those
who have gotten us to a place where we
can have
conversations around radically
reimagining public safety
and ways for caring for one another to
that end i want to lift up the movement
for black lives
organizing in minneapolis namely
reclaiming the black black visions
collected in mpd-150 and those in
ferguson
that on august 9 2014 decided enough was
enough
and played a large role in launching
this iteration of the long black freedom
struggle
we found ourselves at a critical
juncture in history as it relates to
policing and public safety
there's been a resurgence of the
movement for black lives over the last
five years organizers have been building
and developing politically to bring us
to a moment where we can see
and push for a much different set of
demands
specifically the the nation has seen the
injection of abolitionist language and
demands and
into popular discourse in ways that is
unprecedented
abolitionists and those calling for
dramatic shrinking and the scope and
power of policing have grown
increasingly skeptical of popular
seemingly progressive reforms
that have been raised as solutions in
recent years and decades
procedural justice bias training
community policing diversity efforts
use of force guidelines civilian review
boards body cameras focused deterrence
and training centered on police
legitimate police legitimacy have all
been fundamentally called into question
as many municipalities have enacted
these reforms
while the impacts of the various
strategies vary from negligible to
having
some impact on particular metrics they
have proven ineffective in stopping
cycles of police violence
abolitionists such as angela davis ruth
wilson gilmore
miriam caba and organizers from critical
resistance and so many others
have offered black feminist visions of a
world that sees the utter and complete
dismantling of symptoms of
imprisonment policing and surveillance
and the creation of new ways of relating
and caring for one another
rooted in transformation and ensuring
communities have their basic needs met
and the resources to thrive
which has been so critical to bringing
us to the present moment we find
ourselves in
where we can have very different kinds
of conversations
to be sure the persistent policing of
black and marginalized communities is
tied up in larger systems of racial and
class inequalities
essentially racial capitalism itself
those who have presented visions of
abolition and reallocation
have argued for the start of the large
scale reduction and dismantling of
punitive systems in favor
of the creation of just democratic and
non-coercive
as ruth wilson-gilmore states
life-affirming institutions
specifically recent calls for defunding
which anti-violence organizing merit in
kaaba has called a moderate demand
within a larger abolitionist framework
have called for the shift of resources
from policing to the resources that have
been proven to increase safety in
communities
including quality housing dignifying
employment
health care resource schools as well as
alternative emergency and crisis
response systems
even more organizers have called for
reimagining of the ways we address
conflict harm and violence centered on
frameworks such as transformative
justice rather than punitive approaches
that have been so fine-tuned in
america's cultural state
and to ground us i want to center in
this conversation all those who are no
longer with us
as a result of police violence those who
have survived it
and all those including those on the
front lines of protests and organizing
efforts that continue to experience it
in order to bring about a radically
different society and approach to public
safety than the one we see today
and lastly i also want to hold all those
who are trapped in the cages of
incarceration in the united states
who likely needed resources safe housing
mental health treatment
care support food quality education
meaningful employment
but were arrested and funneled into
america's jails and prisons as well as
those who have been jailed and
incarcerated throughout the country
for protesting and challenging state
violence my hope
is that we can root this conversation
today in the long black freedom struggle
and the fight to end cycles of premature
death and ensuring communities have the
resources and conditions to live life
more fully
so let's turn to the conversation again
you know i hope this conversation can be
a generative and productive dialogue
that can bring us
to having a more sense of clarity on all
the words and concepts we've heard over
the past few months from abolition to
reform to the funding and more
and you know i probably have more
questions than we have time for today
but you know i
imagine that uh as mentioned professor
golf and i will engage
in conversation for around 50 minutes or
so before before we uh
include questions um so let's start
professor goff
uh you know you've been involved in work
around police for quite some time
can you flesh out a little more what
cp's work and central area of focus look
like
sure um thank you for that thank you for
crystal
thank you jackie thank you emanuel thank
you vanessa
um we got about 40 other folks on the
call thank all y'all
um there used to be a pretty pithy way
to try and explain what cpe did
nine months ago we said we work with
communities inside of law enforcement to
make them less deadly
and less racist um what we didn't say
was that the ultimate goal was to make
them smaller
so now i say that plus we work with
communities to make them smaller
outside of law enforcement um the way
that we're
known to be to function as we go into uh
police departments
um after asking communities all right so
what is it that is your biggest set of
concerns
we get data from the police department
combine it with uh
either psych data that we collect
ourselves and or census and crime data
and that allows us to draw a map
essentially not just of racial
disparities in things like
juvenile detention arrests use the force
stops
um but the portion of those disparities
that can reasonably be traced back to
law enforcement
because the idea here is that if black
folks are let's say four times more
likely to have force used on them
than white folks in a given community
a skeptical chief will come along and
say but that's just poverty
that's just what about black on black
crime um and
even if we don't assume that that's a
bad faith argument which it almost
always is
um it's reasonable to go in and say all
right so if law enforcement supposed to
go
where crime goes um let's just take that
as a given
then that should uh should influence and
it turns out when you start doing just
the basics the most conservative tests
um that argument falls flat to explain a
large portion of the variance
so you simply defang the argument and
say
do you have anything else if you don't
and you would like to make this better
here's where you can go the work that
we're doing outside of law enforcement
now it follows basically the same
principles
right law enforcement says essentially
in every uh sort of
municipality every public hearing
department of public health says here's
why you need us
please keep funding us department of
education says here's why you need us
please keep funding us
and law enforcement says fund us are you
going to die
they've not had to justify why they're
there
so we're able to go in and say here are
the things that law enforcement does
here's what they claim to do and they
don't y'all make a decision
community but now you have access to it
in a way the law enforcement usually has
not provided
the reason we do it that way is in part
because
as a scholar it's difficult for me i
mean also with this face it's just
difficult for me
to be in front of folks saying let's get
activated over x y and z that's not
where my talents are
um but i have seen from the inside
growing up
you know from west philadelphia to the
suburbs i've seen from the inside
that the temperature in the room has me
was it was making it impossible for
folks who agreed on stuff to get
anything moved forward
and so the analytics make it possible to
turn down the temperature
and move things forward that's most of
what we've done
and in this moment we're excited to be
moving
to decenter policing as part of public
safety
that's what activists were able to do in
the last nine months that
i hope we don't go back yeah
there we go thank you for that um
professor golf so
like you know i know you mentioned that
cpe you know has historically worked
closely with the police and you know
uh and as you have firmly sort of
working with inside
the system and so you know i'm wondering
um
you know sort of how what led to that
that decision
um and and as you said how that has you
know has this current moment shifted
that to sort of the that decentering
um in in these conversations especially
because as you know people
have grown increasingly skeptical of
sort of work that that works directly
with police
so i mean i want to push back both on
part of the opening uh the opening
framing and
and part of that question while i
embrace it at the same time
um so the reason i'll start by doing by
answering the question directly
the reason i started working inside of
police departments is because i got
bullied into it
um that's not an excuse i'm not blaming
nobody else i literally
met a woman um who challenged me to
instead of working in laboratory
settings i'm a social psychologist by
training right
and so for those of you who don't know
the discipline of social psychology our
gig is that we lie to undergraduates and
then see what we do and write papers
about it
um like i see people shaking their heads
but like no that's really that is a lot
of what we do
um and i never felt like that was
comfortable for me to try and generalize
um from you know undergraduates who are
particularly at elite institutions
um and so i wanted to be out in the
field and she said look
come into the police department do the
same stuff out here in the field
and she was coming out of a town hall
meeting a couple years prior to that
engagement
where it was after the the murder of
paul childs who was a 15 year old
developmentally challenged black boy who
was
killed in his own home in denver
colorado and she went to a meetings a
black woman
police at the time captain i believe
went to this meeting
and had another black woman ask her do
you train law enforcement to kill young
black man
now i want to be clear in a public
context that's a really easy question
you say no of course not and i'm so
sorry for your loss
the brave thing to do is to actually
take the question seriously and she did
and she said i actually don't know
so she came to me and said i have this
this question and nobody will try and
ask it with me
we'll try and give me an answer and once
you got in
and you saw what the power of public
safety was and could be
um and i don't mean that in a good way
when you
see the terrifying power of police
unions
in these contexts and the ways in which
folks who are
set up to run municipalities
have no idea how their systems of public
safety work
folks who've had consent decrees or doj
has come in done an investigation
adjudicated them to have had a pattern
and practice a practice that was wrong
and the local male still has no idea how
it runs
it was not conceivable to me that in my
productive adult years
i was going to see a country where you
could say burn it down
start over again so the goal
was to produce systems that would point
towards
the need to take law enforcement out of
places
where they could not ever be doing
anything good
right the solution to homelessness can
never be a badge in a gun you better get
a roof or four walls
the solution like people talk about even
now i'm seeing calls for more critical
incident training
you cannot train law enforcement to be
the best first responders to mental
health crises you just can't do it
it's the wrong tool but if you can't
call for that directly though you can
say it out loud
um if that's not a productive political
path then what are the things that allow
for us to move in that direction
and actually tracking racism in the same
way that they tracked crime
and allowing departments to hold
themselves accountable to that
that seemed like a tool that when every
like first it was just do a study
give feedback to a department but in
every city that was fundamentally the
thing
that the most radical activists and the
sort of everyday traditional activists
we're asking for
give us a way to know how bad it is so
we can hold them accountable for it
and that's how we got it set up so when
you say that people have become
increasingly um or there's increasing
that that feels like a simplification
that i want to make sure
that we get specific about because we
have the space to do that here
there is an ecosystem that is rising
that is ascendant
um that has great and legitimate
skepticism
of i think a broad range of reform
and having been in the space for a while
i can tell you directly
as i said in 04 and 08 and in front of
congress in 2010 and 2012
too much of the folks working in
policing it's a grift
the folks who do implicit bias training
by and large
are doing that like they get paid doing
it they do not consult the scientists so
they cite us in the
in the damn stuff and they they don't
want to know whether or not it works
and the way i know is that we've offered
for free to assess whether or not it
changes behavior in the streets and
folks are patted on the head
i literally got called boy the first
time i i suggested that that be
something that happens
back when i had hairs a long time ago um
so that's fair
but what's been happening over the last
four years
which is incremental and is not aimed at
at the the full scope of the problem it
also hasn't been scaled or tried
honestly
and lump those things together to say
that the folks who are responsive to
what is still a majority of community
activists black folks who have
diagnosed the space as abolition is not
possible
what do we do to build so that it can be
possible to lump that
in with groups of folks who are retired
law enforcement
who's part of their their process is to
give money back into law enforcement
who make a profit off of of doing it and
don't hold themselves accountable to
actual community goals
that feels not just sort of not
uh honest but it feels kind of dangerous
to me
because i i look forward to not like in
anticipation and hoping
but i'm looking forward to a time
when the backlash is weaponized against
this moment
and if we don't have the tools to do the
bold stuff
and the incremental stuff i fear we will
walk backwards because it's not like the
concept of abolition
and the concept of dismantling um the
carsonal state is new
right it is way more popular now it is
way more mainstreamed now than it's ever
been before and that's fantastic
but it gets blotted out in part because
of weaponized white supremacy
so that's my pushback on that the last
part of your question was how it's
changed stuff
and i mean you said it in reflection
what i'm saying we have we felt we had
to do
public safety through the powers that
existed
and we no longer feel like that's the
only path and that is incredible relief
so we've just decentered going through
police departments to do our work
um as an organization um and that's an
exciting path
um to be able to talk about budgets out
loud is an exciting development
um it's an acceleration of the work that
we've been doing
um but it's acceleration like i said
that's not possible without the nine
months of street organizing
yeah for sure um yeah i mean thank you
for that response
and i think the the the piece run reform
at least for me what's been helpful was
thinking about maram caba and critical
resistance
how they frame reformist reforms and
non-reformist reforms
you know specifically reformist reforms
as reforms that provide more resources
legitimacy
um sort of capital two institutions and
and you know
make them more permanent and expand them
and non-reformist reforms that
seek to to reduce the scope and uh
sort of reliance and resources around
around uh policing and everyday life
uh and so that's that's how i try to try
to uh sort of tease that out and so
but you mentioned the funding piece i
know that um cp has has released a road
map around funding and i'm interested
um in the road map and also if you want
to talk about that more about the the
comp set for justice
tool yeah sure um
so let me see if i can let me take
cabba to road map to comstat does that
work
okay um so i appreciate
in all things i appreciate miriam um but
i appreciate the distinction she's
making i wish
that we had a language just to talk i
think a little bit more honestly
um about what that distinction breaks
down into and i'm not saying claiming
that she's being dishonest in any way
shape or form
but i don't think that talking about
non-reformist reform and reformist
reform
is cuts deep enough to what the problems
are
there are there are people who position
and there are reforms that position
themselves
at fixing things with no theory of
change they have no idea
what it would look like if they were
fully successful it's just an idea
to be part of the process and there's
folks who say
i believe that this is the goal and this
is how these set of
interventions move us closer to the goal
right
that feels to me a little bit more
cutting nature at the joints
um than these two different blocks now
we can disagree about what the goal is
but there are folks who are serious
about i want my work to move us in a
particular direction
and they're folks who are much less so
and as all things when you have 115
billion dollars on the table
there are way more folks interested in
getting paid um and there are folks
interested in making change
right um but that to me is is
is a right set of distinctions and one
that's been going on in the space for
the folks who've been doing it
for a while right i don't know that
we're capturing that right now um
in this moment um the reason why we put
out the road map in the way we did the
road map was
i think we i think we put it out in july
um and the reason was
uh so there was the public lynching of
george floyd
and obviously that sparked huge
unrest hundreds of days of protest in
this country and across the globe in
solidarity
um and what happened shortly thereafter
um minneapolis city council in
collaboration
um with activists in minneapolis who
they by the way hadn't been listening to
previously they call for the
defunding which in the way that they did
it would have been a full dismantling
of their police department and right
before they went on air to announce it
i mean it had been reported over the
weekend because they met on a saturday
right before they went on air to
announce it on monday
um they called and asked if we would we
would take part
um and i said look if misky wants to do
it i'm i'm with it
let's let's go so they went on air and
we went on air
and that night we got i think 350 phone
calls
from folks asking how
and then for the course of the next two
weeks they were in the 1500
phone calls there were police
departments sheriff's departments
state and local electeds activists
looking for a way to get there
and there was no way we had bandwidth
you know two years ago we were an
organization of 17 people
we are as of today i think around 70 7-0
um that's we can't we're not going to
deal with 1500 jurisdictions ain't gonna
happen
so we're thinking what is it that we can
do that can provide a map for the folks
we're not working with directly and
closely
so we took the stuff that we knew one
should do that we would do that you
could give away
combined with the research that's out
there that would make some kind of sense
i have a regret in that which is we work
with so the five steps were essentially
do a 9-1-1 survey
where are people calling for police
resources second do an officer
discretionary survey where officers go
in when they're not getting directed by
the public
right and that should give you a sense
of what are they managing like how are
they engaging directly
the third step i believe was focus
deterrence we gonna get back to that
um the fourth step was identifying the
places
that were burdened either by crime like
so by street violence
or by police presence in the absence of
crime because you can do that if you've
done the first two steps
and the force of the fifth step is
essentially providing resources in there
we included focus deterrence because
there is so much consensus
that it's fewer um police resources uh
that it
it should if it's done the appropriate
way foreground community
power to identify the folks like these
are the violence committers we want to
engage them directly
and it provides an off-ramp for violence
before there's a punitive response
i wish we hadn't done that the reason i
wish we hadn't done that
is because it still relies on law
enforcement and punishment
as the route out of violence despite the
fact that there was
that there are uh reductions to both of
those systems within focus insurance
i wish what we had had thought of up
front
was the same thing same exact focus
deterrence
but with universal basic income instead
of punishment as the response
which is where we essentially went in in
four and five um
no excuses on that like we put out a
public document i wrote the darn thing
along with jeff asher and and other
folks
um but the idea was to provide
a little bit of release valve because
what we were hearing from people when we
said we can't get back to you is
like okay if you can't do it then we're
just gonna wait we're just gonna do
nothing
and with the country on fire we wanted
folks to be able to take a step
that looked like a plan where they could
put some data in front of themselves
to calm themselves so that they could do
some things that were significantly
beyond what they could have imagined
just a month earlier not the perfect way
to go
but that was the goal in that now you
asked about concept but i saw you take
yourself off you want to ask me a
question before i get to compensate are
you good
uh maybe dude before because i i
for folks who uh you know might not know
about focusing parents i want to just
sort of
you i think you painted a good picture i
just want to sort of like branch out
even more it's like
a large part it's sort of in that
punitive uh
uh sort of approach is this idea of
pulling levers and it's not only sort of
individuals but in
the entire social networks uh that
people are sort of like
a part of that are seen as part of a
particular groups
um and you know in the idea is that if
one person
you know engages in violence that the
entire group will sort of
you know be will face the sort of full
scope of the law and often they bring in
state and federal
level prosecutors in in that in that
work
um and so so let's let's drill down in
that though
because that is bad focus determines
right i'm saying i don't think we should
have focus turns in there at all
but between gary slutkin who has cure
violence on the one hand
david kennedy's got the national network
for safe communities um
uh pastor mike who does focus insurance
um out of what used to be the pico
network
there are different versions of it
that's the worst comp
where you have a drag net for folks um
who are
connected in a social network with an
individual who commits an act of
violence
the other forms of focused deterrence
are you have a group of folks
who are prone to commit violence
according to past behavior
right they're in a network where we
should identify them as vulnerable
to violence because that's really the
way that those networks are working
and you call them in community calls
them and says we know that you guys are
the most likely
we're blighted by violence if you do it
and you don't go these other routes
we're going to call the cops on you and
you in particular again
wish we hadn't done it but that's a
different kind of focused deterrence
than the kind that says
everybody in the network if one goes you
all go
which is i mean that's unconstitutional
and gross in lots of different ways
mm-hmm yeah and i'm you know i'm glad a
part of what you mentioned is sort of
a shift away from you know sort of a
focus on punishment to focus on on
sort of what does it look like to assess
needs and providing resources as a model
uh as opposed to this sort of sort of
intense uh
sort of unit but you know in terms of
the concept for justice you know
the specific thing that i was wondering
if you want we're able to talk more
about is sort of how
poverty and reports of crime become sort
of
uh sort of a part of the assessment of
whether
in terms of police deployment um
sort of yeah just just talking more
about what goes into the metrics of that
concept for justice and
uh what that looks like okay i'm i i
definitely can explain it but i'm not
quite sure i understood the question
well i guess if we can start by saying
what is the concept for justice okay
so for folks who are not in the policing
space you may have heard of comstat
and it has a terrible wrap it has a
terrible rep only because it deserves it
okay um so what it is
at its root what it was initially meant
to be
you all know how target knows when when
you and your partner get pregnant
um and how google knows what you're
searching for and why you have to
declare the search history because they
looked at the pattern
and that was able to predict what's
happening going forward um and the
argument is you can do that with crime
okay and you can to a degree
right look at past reported crimes and
say these are areas and these are
individuals who are likely to
commit again problem of course with that
is and this is not minority report
we get into like if we want to we can
get into algorithmic justice stuff
um the problem is with that there is no
such thing as crime statistics
full stop that's not an ideological
thing that's descriptive there's
literally no such thing as crime
statistics
there's reported crime statistics so in
new haven
i don't know this for a fact but i'd be
willing to bet
that the place that has the highest uh
rate of underage drinking
is the dorms right i'd also be willing
to bet um
that the place that has that at the
highest rate of what is still considered
illicit drug use is the campus that's
not me trying to knock out the campus
that's just saying any
university town scouting university is
usually the site of the highest level of
what are
still considered illegal narcotics
consumption
but you don't see law enforcement
hanging out waiting to bust up a dorm
party
we have decided that that's not illegal
in the same way
as these same activities are and what's
considered to be an open air market
that's the problem with compstat is that
for the stats folks it's endogeneity you
got the bias already baked in
because you're only stopping black
people in the first place
endogeneity doesn't however mean it's a
useless tool it just means there are
deep problems with it
beyond that this is now just a comp set
thing i'll explain why we get the
concept just in just a second
beyond that it started getting used as a
management tool in a way that
forget about bringing down crime you had
to contribute to an increased
number of stops week over week month
over month year over year
to show that we're doing anything at all
right because if we're not driving the
numbers down
then we're not doing anything is the
logic behind that of course that's
ludicrous
so the green law enforcement can do
anything uh positive they surely can't
do the same sets of things
as appropriate education healthcare
employment
housing right so if they need to be the
drivers get to get down to zero
then at some point you're cutting
corners and you're just doing stuff that
that
corrodes the fabric of democracy that's
why it has a bad rap
but its earliest idea is that we can
measure a thing and hold ourselves
accountable to it
and that helps and there is some
evidence
that when law enforcement holds
themselves accountable to crime that
crime goes down
not just through the measurements of law
enforcement so not just through
uh self-report and that kind of mess so
the idea is since about 80 percent of
major city law enforcement uses some
system like comstat and i think that
number is low
like the vast majority of major city law
enforcement uses a system like comstab
it's part of the dna of how they do
patrol
and deployment why would they not want
to measure
justice instead of just crime and if you
can put it into the systems in the same
kind of way
right and give it over to communities so
the communities are holding them
accountable not just for crime but for
disparity and their portion of disparity
you can de-center crime as the way that
we talk about public safety
and you can re-center community values
there
let me say this last thing in in terms
of of how this works
all the folks who wanted to do the
things that are now getting called for
within law enforcement
the police chiefs who wanted to get
folks out get get officers out of
public health out of mental health out
of substance abuse out of the
homelessness racket
get them out of all of that stuff their
biggest threat is that crime goes up and
what happens there is that even in the
most vulnerable communities like crime
is up what you do and get out
because we only hold police accountable
for crime
there literally wasn't a mechanism to
hold them accountable for something else
statistically speaking in a way that was
easy and obvious
for electeds or for communities so even
in the communities that
that their biggest concern about law
enforcement was racism they would call
for the firing of the chief
if crime spiked so the goal was to
produce
a product that would allow for
communities to have a different metric
to change the conversation and again to
decenter crime as the end-all be-all of
what was going on
inside of law enforcement now phil you
had a question about the the metrics
maybe this is the right time to to ask
about how the quantitative stuff works
and
and the theoretical elements of that if
that's where you were going yeah so in
terms of what goes into determining
right like
this is sort of in this model of concept
for justice how do you determine if
something is unjust or like if there's
patterns in a particular area
disproportionate so it's a great
question and it's something that i feel
like the public
sort of face of this does a bad job of
explaining so i appreciate getting a
chance to
to try and and analyze it this way
com staff for just the way we set it up
is not designed
to do the best science possible
it's not here's what i mean the best
science possible
in the in the traditional academic sense
and i don't even mean the best science
possible
what i would want to do we're that would
be trying to get real close down to
causality
right and we have no interest in trying
to reduce this to causality the reason
being
the data are so crappy
we couldn't possibly do that at scale
it's just not possible
what we're doing is descriptive
statistics
and what we're really doing is
disallowing
one form of argument it is the most
common form of argument so it's
incredibly valuable to my mind
to disallow it if i'm a chief
and you say look at these disparities
you're clearly racist
and i'm remotely literate in this stuff
i say i'm not racist i'm going where
crime is i'm going where poverty is
we see it and we hear it all the time
right like i
i had to spend probably three weeks
beating back the dumbest analysis of
police behavioral data
in the history of christendom saying
there's no bias in policing
are you kidding me had to do that this
summer for three freaking weeks
but it's partially because the argument
is so robust that people like well
it does seem kind of reasonable just
that
so if i take crime and i take poverty
right and i take it off the table right
that doesn't actually that's not a good
way of saying that police don't
contribute to crime itself i actually
have research selling that they do
it's not a good way of saying that
police don't contribute to poverty right
i don't yet have that research
in print we're working on that too but
it does say
shut up about poverty and crime as an
excuse
that it's not on y'all it takes it off
the table
and so what comp staff for justice is
set up to do is to say
even if you were right and crime and
poverty are entirely out of your hands
and they don't over
overlap at all with the things that
you're doing to communities if that were
true
this is the portion that would still be
you do you have any arguments about that
and in every city where we work they're
like i guess i don't i hadn't thought
that you were gonna come back with
anything else
even though in every city we work we do
so think about it in philosophy
philosophical terms as eminent critique
i'm gonna take for granted the arguments
that you've got and you're still full of
it
you still can't justify that the racial
disparities that we see
they're not so it's like property and
crime are not sufficient to explain them
in fact your policies and your behaviors
have to factor in
at a significant level and at that point
what you've done is you removed a bunch
of the barriers
to public safety officials being
involved in change and you say okay so
now we're going to be held accountable
to that
it raises the specter that you could get
in good faith folks getting that portion
of their responsible down to zero
and you for sure will have not have not
solved the problem
i would love to get to that day because
we're nowhere near
in the most progressive most liberal
cities that have the smallest per capita
police forces
and the largest and and best teeth
around civilian oversight
so it's a tool to de-center crime
and decenture those arguments in the
production of public safety that's the
way it was conceptualized
yeah yeah and i mean of course as you
mentioned as we do know though that
there's you know the problem of
endogeneity that all those things are
sort of wrapped up in one another
absolutely yeah and my fear is sort of
like you know with that as i
sort of like was learning more about it
is like this idea that if
you know police then say well we we
solved this gap
so we're only responding to you know
this we're only going here because
it's this level of poverty in this level
of crime then it can reinforce those
sorts of logics that they
should be responding um and so you know
one of the things that came to my mind
was sort of if there
are alternative ways to also sort of
include
um you know like if you're responding to
this because you know
these levels of race or poverty that
this is also like
unjust you know and so um
yeah so it's it's something yeah so so
every city where we roll it out
one of the nice things is be able to
talk to folks right so they're like yeah
so we're only responsible for this 40
was like first of all forty percent of a
fifteen to one disparity
please don't smile that's not a good
thing and secondly
you wanna claim the forty percent this
thirty percent that's you're being
driven by poverty i just wanna be clear
that you said out loud you're okay to go
and arrest poverty
because poverty should be punished with
the criminal legal system
so once you start saying it out loud you
end up with portions of that disparity
that are that are pretty significant
that are morally objectionable to pretty
much everybody in the room
right now you could take it
and flip it and say the only thing
you're responsible is this portion
let's get that as close to zero as
possible and that's used to shut up
um any resistance to uh the ways in
which public safety gets used
to further marginalize communities you
absolutely could use it to do that
and you shouldn't but most of the
the tools that i see that have broad uh
in my mind have broad capacity to reduce
the footprint of law enforcement
are easily tripped up in the exact same
way
so what we i think what we have to do is
get real specific on how we want the
stuff to get used
how we don't get real loud when it's
getting used the wrong way
and talk about the ways in which it's
actually counter to both the moral
valence that we want to put on this
and the science on it i don't think
anybody can justify
um 30 of this of the ra of the racial
disparity here is driven by poverty
as somehow police are doing the right
thing right like i don't think anybody
with it with a decent sense of just
moral center
can make that argument out loud once
it's made clear
so there is the good faith and the bad
faith argument
and then there's the appropriateness of
the tool towards the direction that
i believe you and i are trying to get to
together which is the the full
dismantling
of this state apparatus that was put
into place primarily to regulate
black the liberty of black bodies right
yeah so yeah i mean let's let's i know
you mentioned this before too and so
let's talk about minneapolis um and and
sort of
about a lot of the progressive reforms
that were
have historically sort of been at least
politically attainable and sort of sort
of that have been implemented in
different places and
uh you know cb has worked in minneapolis
um
in concert with the national institute
for community trust and justice in the
years leading up to 2020
and worked collectively and sent out a
great deal of resources to implement
um some some of those those popular
forms procedural justice
uh sort of focused implicit bias
training due to
into intervening policies reconciliation
efforts focus on diversity and community
policing
um and you know you've shared in the
past that it's it
you know at least according to certain
metrics it's reduced particular metrics
of use of force
by 18 but we all know in 2020
minneapolis became the site of an
uprising over the murder of george floyd
that's right throughout the country
um and so you know what does this say
about the the you know
about sort of these popular reforms and
just i
would love to hear more about your
thoughts and how to sort of situate that
yeah so and here again i want folks to
do a closer reading of what happened in
minneapolis
really really do um because there is
grift that's been going on in
minneapolis but there was an alarm
sounded in 2015
about the culture in minneapolis pd um
you know it's it's well known bob cole
who's the current uh union lead
um what his affiliations are in terms of
white supremacist organizations
it's well known who did and didn't go to
uh and who abided by and didn't abide by
policy
um but let's go back to the the frame of
the question
you talk about popular reform and you
talk about significant resources
i want to challenge that because i think
it's not accurate
okay in terms of resources and actually
for those of you who are
asking what he's he's he's asking about
the national uh
initiative for building community trust
and justice um because
doj named it and doj is terrible at
naming things the idea was to take three
things
that we knew worked um in laboratories
and see whether or not it worked
in cities so that it could scale it was
a pilot program okay
um it's about 4.75 million dollars which
i know i got humanists here and that's a
lot of money
right in the abstract let me break down
what that really means there were six
cities
over three years across four
organizations
so for quick math that's 75 000
per organization per city per year that
means each of us hired
one recent college graduate and gave
them bad health insurance
that's functionally what it does okay
during that time there were improvements
in lectures of public trust
that's kind of an amazing thing because
we didn't do a pr
campaign there was no hey look at how
much better we're getting black
communities in particular felt their
police were less racist
in the way that they were being treated
that feels like a really good
metric to me right not just the trust
but the they were less racist
there were reductions in some but not
all the cities um and use of force
um that were proximally attributable to
some of the interventions
and there were reductions in racial
disparities in that use of force
it was a modest gain from a massively
underfunded
initiative which was by far the largest
investment
in reforms that had become popular we
started in
in real time like 2016. i think the
grant was to 2015 but in real time it
was 2016.
they had become popular the year before
so we talked about popular reforms like
stuff that was popular for five years
that's a long time in pop music but it's
not a long time in terms of government
intervention
right they are popular now
because of the last five years where
folks are like oh there's a thing off
the shelf let's go do it
right they have not been funded they've
not been skilled and to the degree that
they've been rolled out much like
community policing
right it started out as a thing where
you should have folks in the community
actually policing themselves community
policing is not
a policing reform it's a community
empowerment reform at its base
it got turned into okay so we should
have community uh we should have police
in the community
and then it's we should have a unit that
knows how to talk to folks and do
dance-off competitions and be a pr
campaign so yeah if that's what
community policing is it's trash it's
garbage
right i said from the beginning that
implicit bias training by itself
is everything about that is a disaster
as we were publishing and popularizing
implicit bias for life people some
some idiot is going to turn this into
just the training i think you could just
do it
check it off a box and be done with it
we wrote that when we first came out
with the science
that's not to say that you can't look at
the situations people are in
and try and reduce the degree to which
their biases
are informing their behaviors right and
then measure whether or not the
behaviors change
so what does it mean in the context of
minneapolis the the backdrop is
these things have been to the degree
that they're popular popular for 15
seconds
to agree that they've taken money it's
massively less than what's needed to
scale something like this to see a kind
of
influence especially in the context of
115 billion industry
but in terms of what it means about
minneapolis
i mean i said to see phil when we when
we spoke the last time in our
pre-conversation
if you do this work and you don't get up
every day expecting to fail
then like i don't know that you that
you're right for the work
but if you get up thinking that these
systems that were set up to brutalize
the sons and daughters of formerly
enslaved folks
are gonna fall to you today it's the
kind of optimism that i think is is
it borders on irresponsible and
dangerous
i personally sent a memo to the chief of
police in minneapolis
in end of march beginning april
saying you know you have a sub culture
in
i think oh no i'm not on mute
can you hear me now okay so i sent him
i'm sent a memo to rondo's the chief
police in minneapolis
end of march beginning april saying you
know you got
um by the way we had stopped working
with them at that point or in a formal
way
um but you know you've got a subculture
that is explicitly white supremacist you
sued them including
naming bob crowe as the head of the
police union sued them for racial
discrimination and won
before you were achieved and you have
had
no success in rooting out that culture
that means everything we've done here
can get flipped
in one incident set that thing right as
covid was studying because i was really
worried what we're going to do is we
were going to criminalize folks who were
non-compliant
which really meant we were going to
criminalize black folks right i didn't
want law enforcement involved
in the enforcement of covid regulations
and social businessing and if we got to
mass wear it
so what it says about minneapolis is
that it's like every other city
there is no amount of inside game that
is going to fix
the mission of policing which at the
founding of this country
when you first had law enforcement was
to regulate black bodies
right and at no point in time did we
take an intermission say okay that was
messed up we should stop doing that
there is no inside game that's going to
do that
it's what i knew going in it's what i
know today it's why i'm relieved to be
able to have
i was the inside game to other folks
outside game right
i now get to be inside and outside
that's a relief living your life more
honestly
more directly but what i hope we don't
do
is what i keep hearing folks say we now
know
reforms don't work to what end
and which communities
right there are reforms that do the
thing they're supposed to do
ain't no reform that's set up
right to fully dismantle tomorrow reform
is harm reduction
and harm reduction is valuable within a
context we look to talk to any public
health person
sometimes the best you can do is harm
reduction especially especially in the
context of addiction
and do i think that we're addicted to a
militarized public safety force of
course we are
so you can't tell me that the best thing
going forward
is to abandon harm reduction in service
of
anti-addiction work they have to go
together
the problem comes when harm reduction is
in the way
of getting us out of the addiction and
that's what needs to happen
to reform folks who are still in that
harm reduction space
that's why i mean that's what i think is
going on in minneapolis right now
they had us in there we were out they
asked us to come back
they've asked us to come back again now
the the process through um the city
council
has been very publicly not what they
wanted it to be
right because there's going to need to
be harm reduction on the way to where
we're going
it just needs to not get in the way of
where we're going
yeah and and that's something i want to
sort of sort of build more on if
so when you say in the way what sorts of
of
approaches have you employed in in terms
of cpe to make sure that you don't get
in the way of those
more sort of bold transformative um i'll
say previous to this moment not enough
probably
right because previous to the moment
like i'm black i'm i'm from philly
uh i graduated high school with mumia's
uh son his youngest son
um i've been in the space and doing this
work and screaming at police chiefs for
a long enough time
ain't nobody really questioning anything
um
there are ways in which folks who work
internally get in the way
that two in particular um that are
incredibly damaging
that i feel like we we did okay but we
weren't as intentional as we're being as
we started being
may 25th the two ways are um
we call the shield and the off ramp so
there are communities where folks they
take the road map that cp put together
and they're like cpu said this we're
going to do this these are the experts
now we don't work there we have no
conversations they just downloaded it
from the website
but there are local organizers like well
we already we already did
a 9-1-1 survey are you just gonna throw
it out like yeah yeah we're gonna do the
cpu way
yeah we already did that but essentially
because we said it
or any national organization said it
that has credibility
outside of whatever local municipality
it gets used as a way to say
hold on not what you want what these
folks know
and so what needs to happen in those
contexts is all of our materials are
being revamped going into 2021
to say we cannot be used as a shield
it's against the sciences against our
ethics
right and we're working more proactively
with organizers in cities where we don't
work
to make sure that they understand if
we're ever used as a shield get us on
the phone we will go on local television
and say
that's mbs we're not with it that's the
wrong way to use our stuff
that's the first way that's the shield
the off ramp um
in some ways is more insidious and more
dangerous right it's part of like what
people will talk about is the
participation trap
and phil this is a problem when you and
i get together it's not just a battle of
1l versus 2l's is that we're this is
inside baseball so let me back up and do
participation trap
right so folks who under uh who are not
in movement spaces understand that
language and then i'll go back to the
offering
for those who are not familiar with the
term participation trap um is the idea
that
you are standing in resistance you are
protesting you were saying something
needs to change
and then that institution says great
let's do it together
and you say okay and by virtue of being
um in participation of being in
collaboration with the institution
the milk toast half measure that ends up
coming out your name somehow is attached
to it
or they'll say oh well they weren't
really collaborative they weren't really
serious so that even the invitation to
participation
is a trap that that derails
the the movement towards the kind of
progress folks are trying to make
that's the participation trap um the
risk for national organizations like cpe
is that we will name a set of things
that this is where you can get to
and that becomes the final destination
for folks as opposed to steps along the
way
and so they say okay we did what cpe
said now we get to be done
it's a common problem in negotiations
politically all the time
so this summer some of you may have been
following the justice and policing act
was put forward by a number of dems in
the house that passed out of the house
didn't get introduced on the floor of
the senate but there was great
consternation and hand-wringing because
it was eight principles
that were good they weren't
abolitionists by any stretching actually
but they were good they were going to
help something
and lots of folks wanted more and then
there were other folks who said if we
ask for that much it doesn't get to the
floor of the senate
and we'll get nothing
are you supposed to do ask for all the
things that you want
right or negotiate against yourself and
guarantee that you get less than
the problem with national organizations
is because there are places where we're
not working
we can be used as that off-ramp to get
less than what local organizers have
decided they want to push for
right and so to articulate that as a
principle that we should not be in the
way of where uh
local organizers are ultimately going to
again work proactively
in the places where we don't already
work to say you should use our voice
to push back against folks trying to use
science to say there is no bias
training is enough training is anything
um in this space
it's not nothing but people use it like
it's the end-all be-all lever
as if individual officers are the
problem um or god forbid
that these set of pollution of solutions
which we suggest are useful
are the end game but it is a hard thing
to do science in the abstract
in a world that isn't abstract to do
science where we're still fumbling
towards
these are the right sets of ways to
quantify this
while people are needing to make policy
decisions right away
so there are gonna be times when we are
getting used as a shield
um and i hate to say this to all other
people who are in this space you too
will be used that way and as an off-ramp
and we didn't get the attention to it
so we couldn't intervene to prevent that
i don't think there's a way to prevent
it a hundred percent i think that we
what can be done is we need to
explicitly say don't do that
don't use this that way and then we need
to devote our resources
to intervening when folks are misusing
our work
to be in the way that way um yeah
yeah so you know recently in colorado
and you shared i'm black men centering
black communities
that means abolishing systems of racial
violence and reforming public
institutions that can be made to reflect
the full realization of black freedom
is policing a system of racial violence
that needs to be abolished or a public
institution that needs to be reformed
so the easy answer for me is it's the
first
right the system that that we have
nope the more complicated answer is then
what do you do with community violence
right like this is the conversation i
wish we were having amongst folks who
are dedicated to what i think is mostly
common cause
when someone is engaged in violence who
can intervene
in a way that can be trusted when you're
new in town
right when you're scared because your
your abuser is also your beloved
who are the folks that intervene there
community violence interrupters
are can be fantastic they cannot be
everything when i talk to eric ford
about this stuff
she's like i'm in that space
and we can't do all the things that the
community needs to keep itself safe
especially
because we're not at a space where there
are the resources
to prevent so many of those forms of
violence in the first place
so i am interested in what we build up
that isn't
policing that isn't named that way that
doesn't have that legacy
i'm invested in helping to figure that
out that's what my science
has always been about and will continue
to be about and i feel like
there's a lot of ideological um
alignment
from all the folks across the spectrum i
said many of them a lot of
audiolife alignment on the end stage but
how do we get there
how do we keep the most vulnerable folks
safe between now
and there all the work that i've ever
done inside of law enforcement was with
the goal
of giving communities power to decide
how they were going to keep themselves
safe
i still stand by that as many mistakes
as i feel like i've made along the way
most of the mistakes are in roll out um
in framing
and relationship i still stand by the
silence by the the science and the
tactics
um but how we get from here
to a future state that centers the most
vulnerable communities
gives them dignity and authority to
determine how they stay safe
and still allows for the fact that in
vulnerable communities
there will be violence i don't know
exactly what that looks like
so when we talk about reimagining this
is the imagination that i think we need
to get to
our best afrofuturists by the
abolitionists that i've been i was
reading since grad school
right they are able to to talk about
things that don't work and some things
that do
i don't feel like i'm all the way there
in terms of having a clear vision of
exactly what that looks like
and i know what it looks like in the
future state but what the transition
that that change
management looks like what we do between
here
and there because i don't imagine a
future
where there aren't public resources to
intercede
when violence is out of hand i do see
systems where we don't have to treat
that like punishment is the only
response
but i don't see systems where we don't
have to intervene in community violence
unless we're abandoning those
communities to themselves which which
creates its own set of problems
so the the short answer is it's the
first and the second answer
is i think way more complicated than
that does that mean does that make sense
yeah you know i think the the question
violence is the one that often comes up
and you know we know that police don't
sort of
stop it sort of in the ways and they
cause different forms of violence until
the the question is
it's then sort of as you mentioned is
how do we build up you know
presence and sort of alternatives and i
think there's a lot of models that
um that we have that that can be scaled
up and others that have to be
experimented and
other folks have said i think you know
there's a need to try everything and
change
everything um as mariam kaplan and luke
wilson gilmore
has shared so you know we're getting
some
uh some some questions so uh
let's ask this one from jonathan um
he shares you expressed pessimism about
the inside game
based around relationship management
with police departments noted that
implicit advice training grifters are
separate from social sciences
i'm trying to get my hands on more use
of force data but police departments
have no reason to give it to me i'm
highly critical
would you or cpe consider committing to
sharing any data sets publicly
required through relationships with the
broader academic community i worry that
if scientists have to maintain good
relationships with police departments to
get data it means police communication
shops determine what the public knows
about race and policing
and this is similar to a question i had
because you know some folks have said
you know
the national database that you've all
built is
you know large but it's not publicly
available and so
yeah yeah and so i'm also seeing in the
chat um
the way in which we we frame uh policing
policing is
violence right and also
in black community after black community
after black community you will find
people
whose lives they say are still there
because
they call the police not police black
folks
somebody ought to interdict right with
violence and if it's not police
there is a lack of clarity about what
that would look like
that doesn't mean i am in favor of
keeping the status quo by any stretch
i'm just saying there needs to be more
specificity as we move through that and
all
i'm for try everything and it's a both
and
but that change management that's a
beast so
to jonathan i think it's john ben monica
okay hey how you doing um
so uh in terms of sharing data uh the
way that the national justice database
got to be the largest uh
uh police behavioral database uh in the
world is that
we didn't require anybody to share
anything publicly
now to be clear we started this right
after trayvon martin was was uh
shot and killed right um there was no
future state where i said in my
productive adulthood
anything like that like like a open
demand would be possible
but it was also the case that we were
already seeing folks who were using
police data to do
really simplistic analyses um both for
on behalf of the police department as if
they were a stats pr
arm folks who take money from law
enforcement um which
in case it's relevant we do not for
exactly that reason
but also scientists who were just not
particularly critical or well trained
um and so what we wanted to do is we
wanted to make a public not just the
data but the analytics
now we had a bunch of departments who
said no thank you we'll take this we're
super racist
that's scary goodbye other departments
um like austin who made it public
which i think made it easier for the
austin collective to argue for the
things that they argued for
right um going forward now that we're in
this new state
um we are requiring that any of the
departments that that come in
brand new to us keep in mind we have a
backlog of about 250.
but any of the new departments and
anything that we're going to fast track
coming up forward
they must make the analytics public
but to the degree that there's been any
kind of concerns around this
i i gotta say i have not had a bunch of
folks reach out and say hey can we
collaborate
i have these sets of questions can can i
get access in collaboration
because there is no restriction on us
bringing collaborators in
setting them up and having them do their
own thing right we've reached out to
folks and said hey you've had a lot of
critical things to say about this
uh scientific approach are you
interested in access to the data that
could disprove it
and i am i'll say i'm not surprised
that when we offer this to folks who put
out their its scientific fact that
there's no bias
they don't want access to the data they
just say the data are not public
and they're not responsive to our
entries please use our data to go ahead
and ask your same questions with your
same methods
so for social scientists who are
interested in who are hearing my voice
right we're gonna have capacity issues
right we're still scaling up to make our
science uh
team large enough to be able to be
responsive but come get some
there's no reason for collaboration to
be off the table
um for the new folks so the short answer
for the new folks coming in we're
requiring them to make that public
our mous require that we can ask we can
encourage
but we can't unilaterally decide to make
the old data public
let me say one last thing on that i
started with and i'll end with it
if you just give disparities if you just
give four to one disparity racial
disparity
um with the data just that simple
descriptive
so and that's by the way that's
nationally police are four times more
likely to beat up black folks than white
folks
right just benchmarked on population if
you just do that
you're going to get folks in the streets
because i told you they were racist and
you can get law enforcement
who are like that's not a reasonable
analysis
and everybody's more entrenched in their
original position so for everybody who
wants access to data
i am in favor of democratizing data i
want more data
but i want with police data in
particular around race i wanted to come
with analytics
i want to come framed responsibly
because otherwise what you end up with
folks big mad about what they came in
thinking and no ability
for change whatsoever and i i hate
seeing science used that way
okay um we we have a question around
defund the police
as we know it's been sort of used in
various ways by
different politicians um for political
capital it's it's
you know also confusion the fundamental
place has just become a thing i know
recently
you've shared uh you know your thoughts
that if it
wasn't framed in that way you know
things like the
the uh surveys might not be be
might have not even been launched but
i'm wondering if if you want to talk
more about
uh sort of cp stands your thoughts
around you know defund the police and
the whole framing conversation yeah i
mean so and i i guess maybe i'll i'll
i'll
uh flag i'm speaking here not fully on
behalf of cp cpe is a
broader organization than just me i get
to be here as a professor at least i
think i do
um my frame on it is this this is one
most frustrating things that i have ever
seen in my lifetime
how are democratic strategists talking
about d fun should have been something
different
how are but did anybody who was talking
defund when it when it when it launched
um
was anybody saying and this is an
electoral strategy
that's like people like democrat
democratic strategies coming out and
saying
i feel like mcdonald's i'm loving it is
not helping people vote democrat
what that's they're not related they're
not the same thing
the goal of the rallying cry was to make
concrete
a set of tactics on the on a way towards
abolition
it is a modest set of recommendations to
say
money that you put in towards public
safety should actually go towards things
that make the public safe
and folks are arguing that it's bad for
electoral politics because
particularly democrats have not figured
out how to speak with fidelity
to black community issues at the same
time that they're appealing
to white centrists that is not
activists problem and it is it is
mind-numbing to me
that we have folks who are yelling at
activists and
i mean the names and the meanness and
the nastiness
as if activists somehow are supposed to
be conscripted in the same
electoral project as professional
democratic operatives that's just dumb
right like it's just it's irresponsibly
unsophisticated
and mind-numbingly illogical to me
if you want to argue that defund is a
bad electoral message
great tell politicians they shouldn't
say defund the police
which almost no politician did by the
way
running for national office but don't
tell activists that they should
reframe the because they don't work for
you
i swear my earbud was fully charged when
we got started um
anyway activists don't work for the
democratic establishment
um and if the democratic establishment
would like activists to work for them
they should give them money
and give them voice in the democratic
platform and until that happens
they should shut the heck up about what
activists should be saying
that's obviously getting activists what
activists are trying to do
folks not doing the work should not be
telling folks doing the work how to do
the work
it's not just defensive it's oppressive
yeah
you know um yeah thank you for that
response and you know one of the things
that you sort of mentioned is in and
sort of as you started the response was
that
you know there's you as a professor you
as a as a person than there's you as
ceo of center policing equity and
you know some of the things especially
the more transformative things that you
you know you've shared on this call
um in this conversation how much of that
gets translated to cpe and sort of like
what's the interplay between
the two yeah it's a good question
because like at the beginning cpe was
just my research lab
right like like i didn't call it nothing
i just had a bunch of undergraduates
running around
recoding police data that nobody had
ever had access to before
right um so it became um
a larger university thing when i moved
from um
state college at penn state out to ucla
and then it was called the consortium
for police leadership and equity
because i was bad at naming things um
but it wasn't even a non-profit until
2017
right at that point it gets a board and
the
the board says you can take money from
here you can't take money from here
um and at that point it is an
institution outside of me
so i'm a co-founder it's me and tracy
cassie um
our ideology our our politics are pretty
similar
um but the organization has a role to
play
and this is the thing that i hope that
folks get
to get the kind of change that i think
again
there's broad ideological commitment to
um that abolitionists have been calling
for and that folks who aren't
abolitionists
but have played abolitionists in their
spare time have been called for for a
long time
to get that kind of change i don't think
we get there without an outside game and
an inside game
i think there's going to be setbacks
there's going to be failures that are
really public
i was really concerned after that uh
asked ed piece i got published in the
times
um and there was the the podcast around
it about minneapolis
because it framed it in the in the worst
possible way
and so the lane that cpe is likely to
stay in for some time
is going to be straddling outside
an inside game i don't think you're
likely to see
um abolition um as the mission of cpe on
its website though
to be fair and i know this it's going on
youtube so i won't talk too bad about
cpe's website the website's gonna need
some help
it's it's it's under it's in the works
uh but i still don't think you're gonna
see it on cp's website because that's
not
that's not the lane that cpe is in
but i worry that we're in this moment
of real short-sightedness in terms of
the history of this struggle
i really appreciate that you put this in
the context of the long struggle um for
black freedom
um and that we're throwing away i see
stuff
in meetings from funders
from allies in this where we got white
folks talking about their abolitionists
and referring to black women on this
college campus at atlanta
getting retweeted and getting lifted up
i don't understand it
there is a kind of venal toxicity
in portions of this space that are
it's just counter to the goal so cpa
will likely to continue to play a role
where it straddles the inside outside
game we have had very little outside
game
prior to nine months ago that was public
um i'm proud of what we've done
previously but it was less than 20 of
what we did um it's more than 50
of what we're planning um and and
likely even larger than that in the next
five to ten years assuming that it gets
to exist for five to ten years
but just because the tactics and the
lane
are different doesn't mean that they
have to be misaligned
and that's what i'm hoping we get to i
hope we're talking more
about the appropriate responses to
violence that don't require
punishment that require investment that
we see violence as a policy failure
every time and that we're able to build
coalition across the various lanes
because if we're making bold demands
and we got nobody bringing the middle
along with us
it's easy for that to just break off and
we get nothing
and the one thing that makes me most
tired out of all this is the number of
times
that black folks have gotten organized
articulated very clearly the ways in
which this country owes
for our sacrifice our labor and we get
nothing i don't i'm tired of seeing it i
don't want to see that in this moment
and i don't want to build things that
are likely to produce that
yeah we we have a question um bringing
it home
to yale um i know that this is your you
know your first year
but um you know i'm sure you do know
that there's there's been a campaign
i'm black students for disarmament at
yale i mean they've launched an invest
dives campaign
and uh yeah and so you know i'm
wondering your thoughts you know
do you support that sort of that work
and
um yeah you know a lot of these
conversations involve different forms of
policing but the conversations around
other kinds of besides municipal
policing like college campus police as
well as sheriff state troopers
you know federal police as we see sort
of in the trump administration
but thinking about college campuses and
um
yeah what that looks like especially
because you know an organization like
cpe
saying we support something like invest
divest and the college campus like yeah
would carry
like weight and so i'm just yeah i'm
wondering your thoughts and how you
relate to that uh
yeah and so i gotta say i am frustrated
at the scheduling of meetings
of that organization um i've been asked
to a couple and i've had
i've had to not be able i just the
conflict was
unavoidable so i can't say that i know
all of the the specifics of the tactics
i will say
i've been involved in some conversations
across the campus about what it looks
like to abolish new haven police
um or what i hear more frequently what
it looks like to abolish the yale police
department
um i am in favor of all
invest in black communities and
vulnerable communities and take that
money
from punishment i am personally very
much in favor of that
in every place that we can do it i think
in the context of university
it could be really interesting because
the real uh
sort of contrary uh audience here
are parents and if you can get college
parents to get behind this then
there's a lot of models for what can
happen across college campuses
right where it gets complicated to me in
terms of
the local politics of it you take yale
pd
and you throw it out okay um as of right
now i can tell you and i've
now had conversations with probably a
dozen colleges across the country
parents are saying that's all fine and
good but there better be cops
when my baby has a complaint to me right
my baby better be safe
and i'm not reimagining nothing right i
imagine that if there's not something to
call i'ma sue you
i'ma take all your money like your
endowment's going to be smaller by the
time i'm done with you
right and so what would happen if it's
new haven law enforcement
that comes in as opposed to yale law
enforcement that comes in
right when i go to eastern parts and
fair haven
but i'm so i'm not living in new haven
yet i'm i'm looking
when i go to black parts of new haven
what i hear in my
quick ethnographies i'm i'm seeing uh we
have somebody here who spent time in
barber shops maurice is in here right
when i'm looking for barber shops what i
hear is folks saying they notice the
difference between yale and new haven
they'd rather get stopped by lpd
than new haven pd and so is the goal
a reduction in new haven or is the goal
uh
destruction of the lpd and an expansion
how does it get done and so what i'm
interested in and what i'm hoping
um will be part of the conversation when
i get to engage with
the undergrads as well as a graduate
group and increasingly there's a faculty
group um
that's interested in this what is the
invest part
what what gets stood up at what pace
with what investment
and how do we then message the ways in
which that can allow us to divest
from from structures of punishment
university of pennsylvania just
committed
100 million dollars to philadelphia
public schools right
that is a great pr campaign i'm really
interested to see how that money gets
actually invested
right but if you of penn can do
something like that
what is yale prepared to do to make sure
that particularly black residents of new
haven
are positioned to be safer without the
need for law enforcement
that's the part that so i i generally
uh endorse and and favorable to the
position
i would very much like to sit down and
talk and to the degree that i can be
useful advocating
hell yeah all of my conversations so far
every university has been
how do you put university police out of
business and if that is not your goal
then i would suggest you get a different
goal
we have a question from demar lewis
which is similar
to some of the things you were just
mentioning um and
that i brought up in the question he
says violence is not the only community
safety concern facing black communities
cities and government officials often
talk about addressing social
inequalities in the abstract but are
unwilling to actually change their
investment strategies or policy
priorities to realize
those changes from your perspective how
do we shift conversations about
community from solely focusing on
eradicating violence to focus on
sustaining social determinants of health
and eradicating persistent social
is cpe actively working to shift the
narrative in this way
yeah and so um i want to do a both and
here and thank you damar
as as always um for coming correct um
i want us to talk about violence because
i want us to understand
if we let out everybody who is
incarcerated right now
who was on state monitoring um that's
non-violent
we got what three-quarters of folks
still left locked up
i want the big changes and if we don't
reckon with violent i mean i
it is hard now not to be responsive to
daniel sarah's book right until we
reckon
um but if we don't wreck it with
violence i worry we're not gonna have
the tools that we need and at the same
time violence is not the only safety
concern
absolutely i am less interested in
de-centering violence
than i am in expanding the center to
talk about what communities are
interested in talking about
but i'll i'll say in addition that when
i go and i'm i'm listening to community
meetings when i'm going when i was
walking around
um uh in new haven and talking to folks
i was like hey so what does it mean to
be safe here i had a real interesting
conversation
um as i was as my wife and i were house
hunting what does community safety here
mean
um it's kind it ends up being either
deeply abstract
i mean the conversation was just leave
us alone
just let us be i want to walk around
and know that no it's nobody's right to
stop me
i was like i'm sorry i didn't mean he's
like no no i'm good talking to you
i just like i know i could walk away
that's kind of abstract the other things
that i hear
end up being low level quality of life
things and it'd be great
to focus on that but that's i don't want
that in the public safety conversation
the quality of life stuff i want in the
public health conversation
so the way so we just had a meeting
yesterday with and i don't know if you
guys have been following american
medical association
just put out a list of principles they
call
white supremacy and police brutality as
white supremacy a public health
problem we've been working with them for
a minute trying to get that out i'm
so excited and proud that the american
medical association has a statement on
police brutality as public health issues
we've been working with um uh robert
johnson and other funders
to make public safety a public health
issue and to take public health
allow that to segment out the things
that police shouldn't have been dealing
with in the first place
that's behind the scenes stuff it's not
part of the public portfolio
i think we'll be messaging about that we
now have a brand new director
of public health at cpe we'll be
messaging about that
but i think the long issue if i can if i
can make my answer a little bit simpler
a long and short is i want to center
violence in public safety because i
think that's a conversation we need to
be having
and way more concretely and i want to
take most of the other things that kind
of are public safety
i want to remove them from that and put
them in public health because a public
health response will be radically
different
than a punitive one does that make sense
yeah um
yeah thank you for that response and so
i want to sort of we're nearing towards
the end but one of the things that i i
did want to ask you about
is sort of you know as you shared with
with the previous question that you
uh sort of imagine an abolitionist
horizon
um but i know in a cnn article from from
a few months ago you you seemingly
argued for a limited but
viable role for police society you know
you say that suburbs are an example
um of what that can look like and so i'm
wondering because
those things seem you know a bit
different i'm wondering if you
can talk more about that um sort of and
if you know in that model sort of what
you imagine police
should be involved within that context
and sort of i'm hearing a bit of a
disjunction so i'm just
um wondering about that and also you
know suburbs are also
you know it they seemingly seem like you
know sites of not police files but when
you go and you know there's often black
and white
in those contexts that are that do
experience routine
uh racial you know racialized police
violence and discrimination
but yeah i'm just interested in hearing
more about that yeah so that
we published that in the midst of uh
sort of the ground shift and under under
feet and so what i was trying to do
um in that article was to make the idea
of reducing the size of law enforcement
um and increasing community control
um less exotic for the hundreds of
mayors and city councils who are
reaching out to us
like this does not have to be scary and
i can't do that by making reference to
afrofuturism
and the history of the long history of
abolitionism within um a black
intellectual tradition
because they're not trying to hear any
of that so the
the talking point was have you been to a
suburb the footprint of law enforcement
is less
per capita um if anybody in the
community or any group within the
community
is outspoken enough it changes tactics
right it is much more mayberry
on than what we get in urban policing
and that was mostly for the urban folks
who were being responsible for that
now i don't know whether or not it made
it into the finals rap i did have a
section saying
um that is of course only if you live
there because if you pass in through
um those are terrible sites of violence
and what we know is that in smaller
police departments the smaller it gets
the higher the rate of deadly force um
in part they'll argue because of lack of
training but regardless
um so the idea is to start making a new
world more familiar
to folks who've got the ability to make
those decisions um
i still think that makes sense as a
talking point to a particular audience
i don't use it in most of the
conversations that i'm having right now
for exactly that reason because we think
of suburban as
a cookie cutter we think about it as
only white but black people live in the
suburbs
right um there's great diversity within
suburbs especially depending on how
they're
they're set up and drawn i mean so
within suburbs you have massive
stratification in the same way that you
do
in urban areas it just looks different
in terms of the experience of it but
that that was just the goal is to make
a future state less exotic for the
people who were trying to make moves
in august i think that i think that's
when they came out august issue
yeah obviously september um yeah i mean
i think we're at about time and um you
know again i thank everyone for
coming out today and engaging in this
this conversation with us
um you know and i hope if nothing else
it's brought you know a sense of clarity
around you know the conversations around
race and policing
i mean importantly you know i think that
it's you know to acknowledge that there
there can be
and i think clarity uh and visions can
be formed through through struggle and
you know i think there can be sometimes
an attempt to you know push and try to
say you know everyone is saying the same
thing and things like that but i think
it's important to
hold you know when people are saying
different things and hold the complexity
um and have you know conversations i
hope that we can we can continue
you know these conversations and yeah
thank you everyone
for coming